hey there and welcome to this lesson on
contrast and how we use contrast in
motion design
my name is cameron and we're inside of
after effects here and i've got a
composition
settings we're calling this criminal
contrast
hdtv
1920 by 1080 24 frames per second five
second duration
a lot of times i like to work at 24
frames per second that is just my
personal preference
you can always work at 30 frames per
second
25 if that's your thing or higher
but 24 gives
a very cinematic feel to motion
that's what feature films are recorded
at
so that's how i like to typically work
it's also less frames to work with
inside of after effects so especially if
i'm working with like 3d
uh 24 frames per second is less frames
to render than 30 frames per second so
24 is typically where i stick a lot of
the times and you're gonna see a lot of
the lessons i work on
are at 24 frames per second click ok
and we're going to build
a design
about a criminal
um based off
one of the images
that really inspired me for contrast
which i'll show you here
so here we are inside of my pinterest
page for motion science if you don't
follow the pinterest page for motion
science i highly recommend that you go
check it out it's got a lot of really
cool boards
on it a lot of great imagery it's very
inspiring
and here's the
the example that inspired me i i really
dug the contrast in this specifically
the red and the black right
um i liked this was based on a 911
i think it's a show called manhunt from
hbo is a documentary
but i just really love the contrast of
this the red on black
very contrasty
very strong statement
works really well same with the imagery
you know black on red here with with you
know no white tones no gray tones just
straight up black and red
love it i guess you get a little bit of
white and gray over here
but it's just very very powerful right
so this is what inspired me to
create the example i'm going to show you
here
and
what i did was go out to google and i
found some imagery
um found some
different assets i'd like to use one of
them is the fingerprint
here's another one this is a document i
looked for like
classified documents court documents
this says investigative report
also
found this document
just an old style telegraph
just you know there's no rhyme or read
like i don't have to have
in designing for motion design you don't
always have to have something that's
very direct to what it is that you're
displaying because i'm talking about a
criminal here like a mug shot
people aren't going to be able to read
these words right and a lot of times
especially in my style design things are
very kind of grungy and distorted and so
it's not going to be easy for someone to
really zoom in here and say what exactly
does that say it's not that's not what
this is about this is about
showing an overall feel an overall look
an overall feel for a design
so i'm just finding imagery that this
appeals to me here's fingerprints on
glass i thought that was really
interesting
some tape
it's really nice looking tape across
here and then i've got the mugshot here
which i took into photoshop and i did a
very quick cutout job you can tell if
you zoom in here look at the edges of
this hair
i mean pretty terrible cutout job but
for the purposes of this design it'll
work just fine we're never going to zoom
way in on this guy
and uh
it'll work so this is from i think this
image was from
maybe like
pixabay or unsplash one of those free
image websites
like i said took it into photoshop very
quickly and just cut out the background
so it's just him right there so let's
start with that let's bring in the
mugshot here
and we're going to scale it down
um
you know i don't know that's probably
too big a lot of times in design
less is more
and i see a lot of designers who will
like if they're featuring a mug shot you
know they're going to start with the
image really big like this right maybe
he's over here maybe he's over here
maybe centered
they're going to make the image the
center image too too big
and it's just it's overpowering it
doesn't look good if we go back to our
inspiration here
like look at this this is one of the the
terrorist hijackers from 911 and you can
see i mean he's not huge in the frame
here he's very small he's down here
um so i'm going to emulate something
like that i'm just going to make them
small scale them down
bring them over here okay
let's also bring in
i have some textures here i've got some
torn paper
uh you can see up here the preview it's
just some torn paper i've also got this
chalkboard black heavy chalk this is a
design asset i use all the time
um it's just it's just a blackboard
right it's very simple
let's
to this chalkboard let's make it have
some interesting edges
over here
and to do that
we're going to go into roughing edges
and
we're going to crank up
the edge amount here quite a bit like
64. and you can see here
when i do that here here's the roughing
edges i'm also going to crank this value
up
somewhere in here so this is width and
this is without right it just it creates
it makes hard edge lines
rough right so let's also change this to
rusty
and there we go so it kind of creates
some interesting cut out
cut out uh looks inside of here and if
you you know if it's not exactly how you
want it uh just play around these values
it's a fun little plug-in
effect to use
um
in after effects i use it all the time
maybe i'll play with the scale a little
bit you know something like that maybe i
don't know it might
maybe make it a little bit smaller try
this way
it doesn't have to be a lot i mean maybe
there that's that's actually pretty nice
i like that
um we're also going to make this a red
background so we're going to go to color
correction tent
and we're just going to tint the white
value
to a red
and then we're going to swap
and
you know maybe something in there
and we're going to turn on our rule of
thirds with option
parentheses
and
let's go ahead and lock that layer and
let's select this guy here
and i'm just going to we'll talk about
um
alignment and things like that later on
but um i'm just going to kind of align
this guy here
his eye is on this point of interest
basically the rule of thirds is to set
this up
you go into preferences general
and under
grids and guides there we go
proportional grid three by
three okay and that's going to set up
these lines three
by three so there's three across three
squares three rectangles across three
rectangles down
and this tells us that this point rule
third says this point here
is our first point of interest when
we're looking at the screen
second third fourth and you can go into
quadrants like this is a point of
interest that's a point of interest that
kind of stuff so
we're just going gonna line this guy in
here
um and
let's actually go ahead and add
a little bit of a background
solid as well
maybe shrink this down that's probably
too much let's go 52
and then let's just add a solid to the
background
maybe like a red black like that
bring to the background so there we go
block that layer will lock there above
it the chalkboard
um and you know
okay cool so let's go ahead and play
with our transfer modes here i like um
let's see
i think darken for this
boom immediately you can see what
happens so if i hit option
uh parentheses here i can't for whatever
reason i can't think of the right words
today
you can see immediately this works right
so just changing this from normal
to darken
wow it's already starting to work really
nice
now um we can go in and we can play with
levels here
if we wanted to be even more contrasty
go to color correction levels
and um we could really boost
you know the gray values here bring more
interest into it maybe
crunch the blacks down even more i don't
want too much right i kind of like that
subtle
i mean you can also go the opposite
direction here and make less contrast
or like in his face right so there's
less detail or we can bring more detail
in
somewhere there you can use levels you
can use curves different ways to go
about doing this
let's also bring in this giant
fingerprint here
and i want it to be black on white
so if we set this to screen that's not
going to work we set it to
multiply
that would work let's scale it down
let's rotate it
um maybe something in here
maybe something in there
um let's bring in this document here
let's see hmm
i'm not sure about that one this one can
kind of cool this is a very large
document i'm going to scale this puppy
down
maybe set it to
darken as well
that's kind of interesting
so i like that i'm going to turn that
one off i'm going to take the one called
unnamed and
said it's a dark as well
that's kind of cool too
[Music]
but like i said you know we don't always
have to have
documents or assets in in design be in
your face right it's okay for this guy
to be really small and kind of
push back in here uh what's most
important to me is actually seeing kind
of like this stamp here and these
numbers here it kind of just you know
based upon when i think of legal things
i think of numbers like this and stamps
and things like that i also think of
fingerprints which is why i have a
fingerprint here
this is really just kind of interesting
in itself
we see that we're like charges you know
even though this is a telegraph
um
because of the word telegraph that's
kind of
that is kind of like say okay well this
is kind of weird why does it say
telegraph here so maybe i'll take that
put a mask on it
subtract it
and if there's any other words that kind
of stand out which i don't think they do
right so
that's kind of cool
this feels
very contrasty here compared to
the rest of the imagery is there's it's
almost like it's too much black right so
let's try let's try darken
that actually works a little bit better
now we could draw color burn
whoops wrong document
now um i think darken's going to work
just fine there
let's also bring in some of this paper
and maybe i'll bring in this guy here
and this these files here these are
massively
huge files
um so first i'm gonna do is i'm gonna
scale it down i'm gonna rotate it i want
something along the top edge
here right something up in here
but i also don't want it to like kind of
take over
the image i don't you know like right
now it's covering up this it's okay if
it covers things up but it's it's very
um it's very in your face at this point
now part of that is probably because
it's um white
so let's go to channel let's invert it
so now we're at black
and i could try darken because dark and
seem to be working well with things yeah
it's purpley right so let's go to effect
let's go to color correction let's make
it black and white
let's actually do black and white before
we invert it nothing okay
so maybe that has to do with darken
okay that's a little bit better
still not totally sold on it
so let's um let's take off black and
white here
and let's try
[Music]
darker color let's actually
you think here for a second so let's
solo it let's turn off the effects
uh let's go ahead and rotate it back
so maybe
if it fills the screen with this white
which has got a really nice texture here
this very subtle details of texture here
if we put this over the top okay so
that's already more interesting you can
see like this line here right
of texture you can also see the texture
in here so if i turn it off
i can see it just barely so let's
actually go into effect
color correction let's do levels again
and let's kind of play around
see if we can bring any of this detail
so we're bringing more detail back in up
here
mm-hmm that's interesting
let's go
let's invert it
let's try bringing an invert above
no
let's try overlay here
that's a little bit too much
so i'm gonna do shift plus and kind of
cycle through these
that's not bad
but you know i've got these um
this ink footage i want to play around
with this as well
um but you know what
this isn't
it's just not working at this point
so i'm just gonna leave it as is for now
i'm gonna find one i like here
i actually liked it better before it was
inverted
yeah not totally sold on it yet
we'll leave it there for
now uh what else we have here to play
around with we've got
the tape let's bring the tape in let's
scale it down
so we're gonna give this like some like
it says mug shot basically so
we'll add some type here
okay so let's go ahead and type
something out here we'll say
uh wanted
for
criminal
activities i think i just spelled this
wrong
um and let's go ahead and just shrink
this down
activity actually i got it right okay
um so we're going to shrink that down
let's actually make that
let's make it red
so we're going to put it over this
maybe over this black tape here
still too big that's another thing i see
a lot of times with uh motion designers
trying to design
is that your type is too big so
something to be aware of we're gonna
bring the type up into this point here
and we're gonna bring the
tape up here as well
and kind of see how that looks
yeah that's not too bad
it almost looks like the tape is being
cut out here
something else we could try here is just
to make a shape layer all right let's
just draw a
rectangular shape layer here
and we don't want it to be filled with a
stroke so we'll turn that off
we do want it to be filled with a solid
color and that solid color is going to
be black
and right off the top i mean this looks
terrible right just
let's actually move the tape
let's
drag it down maybe it's part of like
maybe somewhere in here let's actually
scale it down
so again don't be afraid to make things
small
right
it's okay for things to be small and
let's actually duplicate it
and
let's actually do that trick we learned
before we'll do a negative 15.
and maybe we'll do some rotation here
[Music]
no i'm not loving it so we're going to
turn that one off but we'll lock it
and by locking it tells me hey like
maybe we'll come back and look at this
so this block here it looks nice but
it's too perfect right so one thing we
can do here is we can add some gaussian
blur
so let's add a little bit of gaussian
blur and
let's just crank it up a little bit
maybe
three ish
maybe more
[Music]
and i'm going to hit shift command h so
that i can select
this shape layer but now there's no
bounding box on it right so shift
command h
there's the bounding box when i'm doing
the blur it's hard for me to tell what's
going on so if i do shift command h
again i'm on a mac now i can really
increase the blur here
and this isn't doing anything why is it
not doing anything
hmm
let's go ahead and turn it off for now
i'm not sure what's going on there let's
try
uh effect
it's one of those things but i'll come
back later on big oh of course that's
why it didn't work and as you're
watching this you're probably like oh
it's not working because of
this but uh for whatever reason i
couldn't figure it out uh let's do rough
and edges again maybe let's try rusty
again
that's not bad
yeah i don't want it to be too much
which that's a lot
now let's try uh blur and sharpen let's
try let's try facts box blur here
okay that definitely works
so it just needs to be subtle
so
that's with one a level one maybe it's
like a point eight
you can see it's just very subtle let's
take that below the text here
and i want to do the same thing for the
text i don't this is a trick in motion
design is you don't want your text to
ever be 100 crystal clear
you want to always have just a teeny bit
of blur for this i do definitely like to
use a gaussian blur
and
we're just going to try a value of like
two and so you can see there
it's off on off on
very subtle maybe even a little bit more
maybe 2.5
just helps the text blend in a little
bit better there
so that's looking okay let's actually
collapse some of these layers here so i
can see better i like to keep things you
know nice and tidy
um this this paper is still bothering me
let's go back
up here
and let's get let's bring in this other
paper here
okay so that's already a little bit
nicer looking it's got more visual
interest to it
we could try again
and invert
and go darken
i know we'll get it at some point here
maybe
kind of crunch these values
i mean you can get totally different
looks here just by playing around with
these but
oh again it's just it's uh
it's proven challenging to get it to
work just right
so that's width that's without you know
i don't mind that so bad at this point
so we'll leave it there for now again it
made everything a little bit darker red
but that's okay
let's
find shift command h to turn our
bounding box back on there it is we're
going to duplicate this guy and let's
bring this one over here and let's just
scale it up
and let's focus in on
maybe something like this like i said it
doesn't have to be perfect doesn't have
to line up perfectly but we don't also
don't want to see all of this so let's
do a mask here
something like that let's also feather
that mask
maybe let's draw another mask
and let's just see what this looks like
not loving that so we're going to delete
that mask
and let's increase the feather of this
one
[Music]
we can also drop down the transparency
of this one it just has to be a subtle
texture in there yeah that's not too bad
i like that
i'll tell you what that paper is driving
me insane let's turn off invert
let's go up here
let's try darker color
i'm actually going to keep it something
like this this bothers me way less
than the other one was
and if we play around the levels here
that's not going to do it
that's not going to do it
maybe
you know we're going to turn the levels
off
uh you can see even experienced motion
designers struggle with this stuff so
don't feel alone
let's add another fingerprint here let's
actually let's just duplicate this guy
here
fingerprint there duplicate and let's
just bring it down here just to give it
something down here now not every part
of your image has to be filled with
something there's a lot of like negative
space here
and in here
but i want something small and subtle
here
so i'm just going to scale it way down
you know maybe something like that if i
pull up my grid here
maybe something like that
that's not too bad
and i've also got some really
interesting
um ink footage here
now some of this is from um some
different packs i've downloaded over
time
but
this ink stuff can add a lot of visual
interest
i'm just using option command drag to
replace just to see
you know what looks more interesting to
me and this looks more interesting so
let's go to multiply
again maybe it's going into something
like darken
i like that a little bit better
very very contrasty right compared to
the rest of this stuff
um let's go ahead and duplicate this
layer
let's try number five here
that's nice i like those splotches
as i like to call them
you know i actually like that up there
so let's take four and let's bring four
down
you know and since these are moving
objects as well
trying to find a good point maybe that
something like that would work
and let's duplicate this and let's bring
in let's try 12.
that's nice
just kind of dragging around seeing what
looks
you know nice to my
eye let's rotate it
just needs to be very subtle maybe
something like that
now this one feels like it's too much
let's bring it back
what else we got here
this is nice
we'll set this to
darken as well turn off the sound
now i'm aware of this edge that's being
cut off up here so i want to rotate it
so i would like to try to get something
down in here
right there looks really nice
i really like that a lot
and as i'm looking at this i like how
there's a little bit more detail in the
contrast versus this this is just very
black right so maybe we try something
like multiply
yeah it gives a little bit more detail
brought into it let's go with this one
this will multiply as well
brings back a little bit more detail
we can use something like this over the
entire image right
these are ones that i got from
creative dojo
if you haven't checked out creative dojo
do
vincent he's a
brilliant at what he does
what he teaches
creativedojo.net
that's really nice but i like the red
yeah that one's not working for me let's
try this one
again i'm just holding down shift plus
or shift negative to go forward and back
this is pretty nice right here
it just gives some added uh interest up
in here but it's a little bit um
not enough contrast for me so if i go
into effect color correction levels
again
play around with this
i really want to get rid of these
lighter areas here
so just playing with the gray value here
this white area really bothers me
i'll scale it up a little bit more
yeah that's nice so you can see it gives
some visual interest over here because
of the
the mat the blot is revealing this paper
uh it looks really nice looks really
nice
uh i think
that's about what i'm gonna do for this
stage um essentially i mean we've got a
really nice
layout here the type could be
maybe a little bit closer to his face
to emphasize that he is wanted
you know i'm going to have to look at my
grid here again
that's not bad
if i undo it and bring it back down here
i actually prefer this a little bit more
so let's bring this guy let's bring his
mug shot
maybe a little bit closer in here
but then i don't like the negative space
here okay
so it's all about balance right and
you're gonna learn about balance a
little bit later on as well
maybe it's a matter of
bringing
this guy
over in here
yeah see how i like that better so there
you go there is our
criminal contrast design i think in the
next video we're going to look at uh how
to animate this if we wanted to animate
this and bring it on how would we do
that so we'll do that in the video
coming up next
[Music]
you